نقلت صحيفه نيويورك تايمز عن قاده عسكريين
اسرائيليين قولهم ان استعاده الرهائن
ممكنه من خلال الوسائل الدبلوماسيه
للعسكريه واضاف القاد العسكريون
الاسرائيليون للصحيفه ان استعاده الرهائن
وتدمير حماس اصبح الان هدفين غير متوافقين
وان المعركه الطويله الهادفه لتدمير حماس
ستكلف على الارجح حياه الرهائن واكد
القاده الاسرائيليون ان المسار الدبلوماسي
لاستعاده الر سيكون الوسيله الاسرع وقالوا
ان المازق الاستراتيجي ادى لتفاقم احباط
الجيش بشان تردد القياده السياسيه وعبر
العسكريون الاسرائيليون للصحيفه عن خشيتهم
من ان يؤدي طول الحمله العسكريه دون خطه
لما بعد الحرب الى تاكل دعم الحلفاء من
جانب اخر قالت النيويورك تايمز انها اطلعت
او اطلعت على وثائق تشير الى ان اسرائيل
فرضت سيطرتها في غزه على جزء اصغر مما
صورته في خطط المعركه منذ بدايه الحرب
واشارت الوثائق الى ان الخطط الاسرائيليه
تضمنت السيطره على مدن غزه وخان يونس ورفح
بحلول اواخر
ديسمبر